sasà sap mamma mia che goduria sentire
un audio così sul mio canale che cos'è
sembrano youtuber professionista prima o
poi dovevo fare questo salto di qualità
ho solo dieci anni su youtube però vabbè
bella stessi ragazzi benvenuti questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi iniziamo
uno di quei video dove volevo discutere
con voi di cose di macro argomenti ecco
volevo appunto iniziare questa questa
serie di video in cui parlo di cose che
mi interessano e volevo e voglio proprio
discuterne con voi in realtà con saranno
video dove io parlo è finita qua bastano
in realtà siamo proprio arrivati in un
momento della mia carriera dove voglio
avere dove voglio avvicinarmi il più
possibile a voi e avere un dialogo con
voi ok uno dei primissimi argomenti
quello che tratteremo in questo video è
la moda in che senso quando io ho
iniziato a fare video sono andato ho
iniziato subito ad andare di moda ok una
cosa molto inusuale in realtà perché il
mio successo è proprio schizzato alle
stelle perché nessuno stava facendo
quella cosa lì in italia fuori sede e
quindi quel tipo di gameplay ha preso
piede quindi ho subito iniziato avere
successo ben come fa un qualcosa ad
avere successo la gente ne parla
ok quindi io immagino che gran parte di
voi mi abbia conosciuto
dei video correlati perché youtube e li
propone quando un video e conosciuto lo
propone a più persone va bene e molto
invece mi hanno conosciuto perché ve ne
ha parlato qualcuno di me questa seconda
cosa quindi il qualcuno vi ha parlato di
me è proprio il fulcro di questo video
secondo me la moda rende le cose
popolari quando un qualcosa viene visto
tipo squid game quiz game tutti parlano
di squilli game cosa faccio me lo vado a
guardare perché tutti ne stanno parlando
e bene questo è un concetto banale
quindi visto gli sto spiegando l'acqua
calda vabbè però e questa cosa è molto
molto strana se la analizziamo almeno
dal mio punto di vista è molto strana
perché perché squid game
ok perché fort night perché per esempio
parla di formenti proprio perché la tipa
il personaggio di animal crossing
che si in groppa un kit perché parte la
moda di queste cose e non di altre
capito partendo proprio dalla tripoli
arrivano i cross di governo su dei siti
non altri si vive su altri new anni fa
ma proprio penso almeno credo almeno tre
o quattro anni fa pubblicano questo
video di questa di questo personaggio di
animal crossing che si
fantastica in pop tra l'altro è un
qualcuno va bene lo so qui passano anni
passano un sacco di anni quest'anno 2021
non so da quando ma più o meno un paio
di mesi quindi da 8 ottobre di inizio
ottobre diventa
popolarissima una cosa che già esisteva
da anni ma proprio da c'era già semplice
è come se io pubblicassi un video oggi o
che io pubblico questo video oggi e in
un mese fa 100.000 chiuso due mesi fa a
105.000 views 110.000 josé eccetera poi
nel 2025 il già il 3 giugno del 2025
questo video fa milioni di inizia a fare
milioni di views perché perché una cosa
diventa popolare da lui
la questa cosa è molto strana perché se
un qualcosa viene creato adesso diventa
popolare allora dice va bene e se è
stato talmente bello che è diventato
popolarissimo tipo scud game quindi è
uscito in tempo un minuto ha fatto
numeri incredibili ma non è solo questo
perché con l'esempio di attivare nuove
classi esisteva da anni ed è diventata
famosissima dopo tantissimo tempo quindi
non era così impattante da avere un
successo globale
all'inizio quindi perché dopo se cos'è
che crea la moda
boh io ho provato a darmi delle
spiegazioni non sono sicuro di saperlo
perché non trova una risposta semplice a
questo perché un qualcosa diventa di
moda quando sempre esistito mi ricorda i
tempi parti vi parlo del 2016
diventa famoso forse di più del 2018 non
mi ricordo diventa famosissima l'app che
ti invecchia tutti itis invecchiavano
sui social mettevano foto di da vecchi
perché c'era questa app che ti
invecchiava quella pesiste va da 10 anni
quella pre sistema la usavo addirittura
anche io nei video nel 2015 li facevo
quindi anni anni prima nei video di face
up dove mi misi miss mappa non la
facciano quella roba lì che perché io
facevo su youtube ci sono quei titoli
c'era anche quella che ti invecchiava
quindi perché è diventata famosa quella
roba nel 2018 e 19 più o meno perché
perché una cosa che esisteva diventa
famosa a carissimo questa risposta è
difficilissimo da trovare e ovviamente
c'è il perché ma non so che cos'è che da
dove la magia che fa esplodere il tutto
quanto questo non lo so ovviamente che
cosa che fa diventare famoso un qualcosa
quando tutti ne parlano ok quindi perché
voi conoscete altri pacchi animal
crossing adesso e non un tempo ma i veri
man of cultures la conoscevano prima
perché la gente inizia a parlarne un
sacco ok quindi ed è per quello che la
conoscete oggi quindi perché conosce the
squid game perché la gente ne parla un
sacco perché conosce the game of thrones
io non l'ho ancora neanche visto perché
la gente l'ha guardato e ne ha parlato
un sacco quindi ti viene da dire mica
tutti parlano di sta roba magari ed è
così che diventa famosa una cosa ma
la domanda che mi sorge spontanea se si
capisce bene che cos'è che fa partire un
qualche cosa per far sì che se ne parli
sarebbe possibile rendere famoso un
qualsiasi cosa
secondo me la risposta è sì c'è nel
senso io prendo il mio telecom abilmente
quando giacomo da una roba che non è il
mio fazzoletto sporco dove mi sono
soffiato il naso ok io prendo sto
fazzoletto qua non se lo caga nessuno un
fazzoletto
se io faccio in modo non so come ma fa
in modo che diverse persone parlino di
questo fazzoletto questo passate orienta
famosissimo bisogna capire dove dove e
come farne parlare in modo tale che
quelle persone che ne parlano lo
facciano diventare famoso secondo me
esistono di cosi per far diventare
famose delle cose che non sarebbero mai
diventate famose se non si fossero
concatenate queste serie di situazioni
ecco questo volevo dire questa cosa è
molto strana c'è veramente io ancora non
me lo spiego perché e adesso vi ho fatto
degli esempi ma tante cose sono così ma
proprio tante ma non solo oggetti sotto
esempi di film e applicazioni oggetti
anche persone c'è adesso io non faccio
nomi eccetera ma sicuramente nell'ambito
della del mondo dell'intrattenimento
siccome ci sono persone che sono famose
perché sono famose che cosa fanno queste
persone niente sono solo famose e quindi
generano altra fama ma che cosa stanno
facendo poi ovviamente non puoi non fare
niente quindi poi ti metti a fare
qualcosa provare a fare qualcosa però
c'è proprio esiste questa cosa che se vi
dico questa cosa io voglio fare io
faccio parte vita che non sono famiglie
che mi chiamo pinuccio ambrogini voglio
fare il cantante
ok pubblico una canzone su youtube e
canto canto anche bene magari non mi si
caga nessuno perché di cantanti ci sono
tantissimi io sono sempre più su
ambrosini farci un video in cui canto e
in qualche modo mi elogio già
anzi mi faccio elogiare già nel senso mi
metto d'accordo con delle persone del
settore che mi trattano come se io fossi
già affermato quindi non come una
persona da scoprire ma con una persona
già che è già arrivata ok asi
l'incredibile pinuccio secondo me pino
cembro diventa famosissimo in tempo zero
perché la gente ne sta parlando anche se
non sa chi cacchio è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tutto questo si riassume con la moda la
moda funziona così la gente fa sì che si
parli di una determinata cosa se tu sei
già conosciuto lì è più facile perché
sei già conosciuto quindi fai parlare di
te in diversi modi non è il mio caso
perché io odio la fama come sapete tutti
però io credo
che questo sia
il mondo dell'intrattenimento generale
qui non solo il web proprio il mondo
generale nell'intrattenimento oggi ed è
molto strano quindi ragazzi per
concludere la moda è molto strana non
l'ho mai capita so che esiste so che ci
sono dei meccanismi che non comprendo ma
so che esiste un po come lo spazio
l'universo sappiamo che ci sono
determinate cose non le possiamo vedere
non sappiamo che funzionano ma sappiamo
che ci sono e niente quindi io spero che
vi sia piaciuto spero che sia uno spunto
di riflessione e di dibattito europeo
del genere fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate
nei commenti perché veramente questo
tipo di video sia si vuole proprio vuole
proprio dire questo cioè voglio creare
un dibattito su determinate cose io
chiudo qui il video ci vediamo dopo
domani con un altro argomentino trattato
iscrivetevi al canale sono stati scritti
e noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]